stand-up comedy has a rich history of
being associated with being against
censorship it's it's you know comedians
are contrarian so you tell a comedian to
not do something similar to a
five-year-old that's sleep-deprived that
will be the first thing they do if you
see do not go on stage do not talk about
the CEO at this corporate event
comedians will instinctively do that so
any form of censorship is
counterintuitive to a comedian so
comedians pride themselves on saying any
topic is nothing's off-limits that being
said I also think that as a comedian I
believe that there's nothing that's
off-limits but I also think that human
beings were constantly censoring
ourselves
I'm censoring myself right now for this
I'm trying to appear smart and I'm not
doing that good of a job but I do think
that the PC culture in my opinion is of
great value you know we should always
strive to be more sensitive and
understanding and similar to the concept
of Liberty which I mentioned before it's
ever expanding so well the I our idea of
freedom today is is it's a much better
fulfilling idea of freedom than our
founding fathers even envisioned
probably but it's the same notion of
freedom so the idea of politically
correctness I don't think that has to do
with censorship I think that has to do
with a certain sensitivity so you know
words that are very toxic it's it's
unnecessary you know if you also
identify yourself
a clean person it's not necessary to say
shocking words that being said there are
great comedians that deal in shock that
deal in a reverence but similar to
Liberty a reverence
what's a reverend today is still
tomorrow so if you chase a reverence
that's that's a pretty slippery slope I
mean Don Rickles can do it but there's
been a lot of awkward moments for Don
Rickles even on a public stage but I
don't know I it's also very personal but
I think that whatever we call political
correctness or whatever the term might
be you know saying things that aren't
sexist or could be construed as racist
it's not that hard of a sacrifice now
that's not to say that people aren't
overly sensitive I think the bigger
issue which I even we did an episode on
is the fact that we are humans and there
is the mob mentality that same mom
mentality that would go on pogroms in
Eastern Europe is the same mentality
that people engage in when someone does
a tweet that's a poor taste so I think
it's not so much the crime it's the
punishment and I think that human beings
I feel like we have this arrogance like
every generation thinks we got it
figured out we're the greatest
generation we got rid of you know
fascism when the reality is is that
every generation thinks we figure it out
medical science we've got it we're
scientists what we do is we leach bodies
and that's how you cure diseases there's
an arrogance there that we don't even
today we're like we've got to figure it
out you know
you know like we like even with the
transgender thing I think that there's
almost this sensibility like we finally
figured it out everyone's equal once we
get these trans people but there is a
bigotry that exists in our culture that
we're not aware of that our children
will point out and we will be as
resistant as our parents are to certain
things like that's not homophobic but
they you know you know my parents were
very liberal for their age but I
remember when I moved to New York in the
early 90s I just thought it was so funny
when some of my friends from New York
would say people in the south they're
prejudiced all of them and I just
thought that was great irony really all
of them isn't that ironic so it's it's
something where I just think that
there's a certain amount of humility and
that we should carry I'm not saying I
execute that humility I'm just saying as
an observer whether someone it's like
everyone makes mistakes
I mean I haven't since like 81 81 I made
one mistake then no mistakes but I just
think we should be more forgiving and I
think it's more interesting the Teflon
people and I mean that as a compliment
people that there are some people that
can make mistakes and it doesn't bother
them on a social in a public atmosphere
and some people making one mistake and
they're guilty forever and they're
indicted and I think that goes back to
our mob mentality so in the end were
animals for like these strange tribal
people that like you know everyone who
gets around on Sunday night and watches
Game of Thrones and watches these
strange this strange culture of this
made-up
world like we don't have the awareness
that we're just as crazy as that world
of Game of Thrones we just don't want to
look at herself anyway I'm a great guy